I'm sitting here with one of my longtime
friends and one of the greatest
basketball players alive Kyrie Irving
how you doing man
I mean I'm in your room now this is the
people disappear home so there's a beam
on show that you helped make because
you'll and Kyrie you lend to your
celebrity to our pilot only people that
yeah come on it's true I'm Ali Lister
you're see literacy Lister you're an NB
a Lister off the dome on the card look
for NBA Lister on that card you love
musicals and I do I knew that about did
you I do okay you're a musical fellow
want to sing your name
[Music]
you coming down here tear life were
musical would you go to it like in 2011
you dropped in your first pick by the
Cleveland Cavaliers there might come out
like yeah as a musical yeah so I mean
when you were drafted your first peg oh
I'm so nervous for I'm gonna have doves
coming out of we can luckily load does
and I know when you're picked you go by
the cab since we met a few years ago
you've made the all-star team twice how
much do you think I had to do with that
one it's the lowest percent what how are
you sleeping sleeping alright you sleep
on your back I like to change it up
every once while you mix it up
I like no pillow sometimes I sleep on
top of the covers one when I go again
you're mixing it up mm-hmm
your bed doesn't know what's coming no
just like your competition oh well
played sir
what's worse getting crossed on getting
dunked on or getting a shot blocked
getting crossed really what's definitely
Dikembe Mutombo said that getting dunked
on yeah I think his job was to protect
the room yeah you're more of an outside
man yeah the perimeter defense bring it
in the paint you know mm-hmm
keep it out of the paint
yeah here you go can you palm a
basketball yes I can have you ever
pawned a small child yeah my little
sister ones really yeah a picture of our
head got trouble for it you know really
what is it go there soft spot yeah the
sauce spot well you got a palm it don't
don't turn our legs do we differ yeah
man
speed Stewie you want me to grade you
give me a chance okay hey Brian
hey oh the one where it gets real roided
i stoie something different about you oh
oh that's nasty make a lot of serious
faces when you play basketball
yeah that's the face what do you what if
you like how show me how you feel in
your heart really goes in and everyone
was hot it was like the last second show
me let's show me the real face yeah I
knew you had it in you
you broke your face I did then you have
to wear a helmet
no no wear mask I was called the Dark
Knight really that's cause you were
scoring so much I mean I was taking care
of business
in Gotham City I'm not the man come over
there that's a good thing I'm gonna
crash over and not being the paint you
long as I finish you without permission
to shoot free throws
just one County one is not enough about
man it's not a bad baby
I like me he's awesome have you ever
cried on the court
yeah good tears or bad tears both do you
play this game to win the love and
affection of your father or is it for
the cash and them hoes so I guess it's a
combination of both Kairi thank you so
much for sitting down with us again
you're amazing thank you good luck in
the in the match
[Applause]
[Music]